[Musique]
ce matin-là auprès au dos la lumière
d'automne du haut doubs est propice à la
nostalgie
pierre durand champion olympique en 1988
évoque la victoire de sa vie avec émile
péquignet sponsor officiel à l'époque de
toute l'équipe de france d'équitation
présente à ses ouailles magnifiques
souvenirs magnifiques souvenirs
tu vas pas savoir ce que c'était
impressionnant parce que ce couloir il
faisait bien 60 m 1 facilement et on
était tout seul non ce tunnel est au
fond il n'était pas éclairé et tu voyais
le halo de lumière tu sais et je savais
que la dalle est rentré dans l'arène
pour jouer ton sort de sportifs
allemands quelques mines dont moi même
pas tout le monde
on était tous stressés silence pas un
bruit dans les tribunes et puis et puis
on est à attendre le dernier saut
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi je dis ça me
ça me prend aucune excuse
avant que ne débutent les épreuves 300
montres fabriquées à morteau avait été
offerte aux cavaliers et à leurs
accompagnateurs
on est quand même forcément un peu
superstitieux quand on est sportif et je
me suis dit cette monte à l'importer
chance donc gelé mise tout de suite
donc j'ai fait tous mes parcours etc
cette montre donc a été vraiment
championne olympique
rarement un lien entre sportifs et
sponsors n'avait été aussi fort et aussi
légitime d'ailleurs aujourd'hui encore
emile picquigny continue de monter
chaque matin par contre un peu coquine
est capable de la mettre par terre à
l'entreprise elle a choisi de rappeler
cette histoire et d'y associer pierre
durand et son incroyable cheval en le
gravant sur un boîtier historique de la
marque
c'est vraiment la silhouette de jappo
très caractéristique donc de lui qui
évalue à 2 foulée l'obstacle à hauteur
des obstacles étaient généralement
beaucoup plus haut que lui un modèle
homme automatique un modèle femme à
quartz ceux vendus entre 850 et 1150
euros qui seront mises en fabrication à
la demande et numérotées pour les 300
premiers exemplaires c'est de mon
travail j'essaie d'en passer d'être
complètement revisitée restylée et on
l'a adapté sur sur jappeloup on a adopté
un principe de souscription c'est à dire
que on lancera la production une fois
que l'on aura les 100 souscription
requises pour relancer la prod dernière
médaille d'or française de l'histoire en
saut d'obstacles individuel
le couple durant jappeloup à cette fois
définitivement lié son destin à la
manufacture horlogère demande
[Musique]
collectionneurs
l'été